we miss having you next door you were
shooting next door here for a while Pete
Holmes and very funny stuff thank you we
loved having you there it was an
absolute dream come true every time I
see you I can't thank you enough it was
the best time on my life we were
neighbors we were neighbors in timeslot
we were neighbors here on the lot I was
evicted hey your dues oh no I was thrown
out because I wasn't paying rent yeah
but it was the best experience of my
life and you've changed my life I can't
thank you you get like recognized do you
get do you get in time to time
yeah hang out with you we are different
levels of Fame your you know your your
paling uh-huh you're pale and redheaded
uh-huh you don't blend in as well as me
no I don't blend in now I've tried to
blend in it doesn't happen no there's no
blending I can blend yeah
I'll blend pretty good but sometimes
people do want me to sign things which
is new for me I sign autographs now but
people never know what to give me to
sign I also have to write my autograph
very legibly it's kind of like we want
your autograph and we're also not sure
who you are so if you could write it
down
ah pre toms yeah your father's Jr's from
thanks a lot yeah so I will sign
autographs and every once in a while I
actually brought a photograph of my
favorite autograph that I had to sign
because the guy didn't have anything for
me to sign and he had me sign the best
of Nickelback so he had to sign there it
is the best of Nickelback
that's fantastic volume one and I don't
know if you can read my handwriting but
I wrote look at this autograph good that
was pretty good most of the time people
have no idea who I am every once in a
while because of the great opportunity
you gave me people will recognize me one
time a girl in New York City wanted a
photo and you have to be gracious you
can't be a jerk and like flick a lit
cigarette Adam and Eve in showbiz do
that you can't do that get on a
motorcycle a woman is driving and just
drive away so I took a photo with her
obviously
and then this guy that was in a cab he
was idling by the side of the road saw
what happened he clearly had no idea who
I was but he started yelling at me very
New York City thing to do he's there
going hey you're famous
you're famous I saw you get over here
and I tried to lose him but you know I'm
on foot he's in a car he just takes his
foot off the brake he's going faster
than I am so he's cruising along with
you yelling you're famous no idea so I
went over to him he stopped and gave me
a taxi slip and he goes give me your
autograph
your favors make you feel good yeah made
me feel confused but I knew he knew he
had no idea who I was but he had a pen
on paper so I just wrote best wishes
Amy Schumer
[Applause]
that Amy Schumer's a tall man
you